a zucchini squash was peeled and cut
into six identical cubes after being
weighed each cube was soaked in a
different sucrose solution for 24 hours
in an open container and at a constant
temperature of 21 degrees Celsius the
cubes were then removed from the sucrose
solutions carefully blotted on paper
towels and weighed again the percent
change in mass due to a net gain or loss
of water was calculated for each cube
and the results are shown in the graph
below I put the graph to the right right
over here a straight line is drawn on
the graph to help in estimating results
from other sucrose concentrations not
tested using the straight line on the
graph above calculate the water
potential in bars of the zucchini squash
at 21 degrees Celsius give your answer
to one decimal place so pause this video
and see if you can have a go at it
alright now let's do this together so we
have our six cubes of zucchini squash
and we have each of these data points
are the data for each of those cubes so
for example this data point shows a cube
that was put into a solution that
contains no sucrose and when it was put
into a solution that contains no sucrose
it gained 20 percent mass and that mass
would be from the water going into the
cube so one way to think about it is it
got put into a solution and so you had a
net inflow of water into that sucrose
cube enough to increase its mass by 20%
this second data point right over here
it was put into a solution that is 0.2 0
mph / liter of sucrose and that also had
an increase of mass but it was a smaller
increase of mass and then we could go
all the way to the extreme right over
here where we had a where we had a
zucchini cube put into a solution that
had a lot of sucrose in it one mole per
liter and there you have a net outflow
of water it decreased the cubes mass by
30%
so how do we figure out the water
potential of the zucchini squash well
one way to think about it is we could
figure out the water potential of
zucchini squash is if we put it into a
solution that has a certain sucrose
concentration and if we have no net
inflow or outflow of water in either
direction that means that the zucchini
squash and the sucrose solution have the
same water potential and we see that
happening at least we can interpolate it
right over here because if we just
follow that line it looks like if we
were to put it put our zucchini cubes or
a zucchini squash cubes into a sucrose
solution that is this looks about let's
see this would be 0.3 so let's just call
that 0.36 molar solution 0.36 molar
solution well then it has the same water
potential as that solution because you
have no net inflow or outflow of water
so the zucchini squash water potential
is going to be the same as the water
potential of a solution of sucrose that
it has there 0.36 moles per liter so we
just have to figure out the water
potential of that well the water
potential formula we know and we've seen
this in other videos is equal to our
solute potential plus our pressure
potential we know that these are open
containers so the pressure potential is
going to be zero and so we just need to
figure out the solute potential of our
sucrose solution with this concentration
well we know our solute potential is
going to be equal to negative I where
this is the ionization constant for
every molecule of sucrose does it
disassociate into when it gets put into
water
well sucrose doesn't disassociate it so
it would just be 1 times our molarity
times what's sometimes called the
pressure constant but it's really the
same thing as a universal gas constant
that you might have learned in chemistry
times the temperature in Kelvin so this
is going to be equal to negative I
already said that this I is 1 because
the sucrose just stays sucrose when you
put it in water so negative 1 times 0.36
I'll write the unit's moles
per liter times our and if you're doing
something like an AP test they actually
give you these formulas and they even
give you R as being zero point zero
eight three one liter bars per mole
Kelvin and then times the temperature in
Kelvin well if we're dealing with twenty
one degrees Celsius we just add 273 to
that so times 294 Kelvin and now we can
just get our calculator out negative one
times 0.36 times 0.08 3 1 times 294 is
equal to if I round to one to one
decimal place it's going to be negative
eight point eight negative eight point
eight and the units work out as well
moles cancel with moles liters cancel
with leaders Kelvin cancels with Kelvin
and we're just with left with negative
eight point eight bars and we are done